we're also not really addressing
the lgbtq community who and that's where
i say like feminine and masculine traits
which you can define that you know
nurturing feminine or whatever
lesbian couples sometimes gender
exclusive exactly that's exactly what
i'm trying to say they know that yeah no
so i'm saying uh when we're talking
about like alpha male and alpha female i
think that what we're talking about is
relationship dynamics
and that somebody needs to be the
provider and somebody needs to be the
nurturer that's the way it is
i don't want to get canceled right now
but it's typically like the prettier
feminine one and then like the dynamics
the butcher masculine short-haired
lesbian masculine and feminine will
still ex it's a human condition that it
will still exemplify itself or manifest
itself even in homosexual relationships
there's the butch there's the butch dyke
and then there's the feminine sub dyke
yeah the lipstick one
and so one assumes the masculine real
hell there was a what was it a i think
it was oprah winfrey was doing a show a
way way back about like sexual fluidity
in women and suddenly they go like from
like being 39 40 41 years old somewhere
around there and they suddenly discover
that they're lesbians and they can't
they can't get well they can't find
a dominant masculine man to be part of
their lives and so what they do is they
look for a dominant masculine butch
female to be to sort of fulfill that
role yeah and there the reason why she
was doing that show was because it was
so common that she had
they wanted to address this and the
problem that that you run into is then
is she
born that way or is she just pushed into
that position because of her
circumstances and her situation what do
you think the answer is that that's the
jury's still out on that well according
to lady gaga she was born there well
somebody yeah exactly so um i mean if
you're going to ask me personally i
think that it's a behavioral
response to conditions after 40 years
you just realize there's got to be some
sort of uh sexual fluidity but we still
just be i'm straight and now i'm gay
yeah well that's the thing is though is
okay well if that's fine then do i get
to say well suddenly i'm gay and then
i'm not gay today or whatever is it's
the subjective definition for whatever
you feel or is it are you is it a
biological condition because up to this
point we that's all we've been saying i
was born this way my genetics i can't
help feel but the way i do and i believe
them but i think it's behavioral not
necessarily a genetic thing okay
well tyler
thank you for the question
[Music]
you